it isn't often that snow falls on the
White House in October snowfall is also
rare New York at this time of year and
this weekend was just the fourth time
it's fallen in Central Park since
records began 135 years ago in New
England where snow usually falls in
early December the record-breaking snow
was heaviest in Jaffrey in New Hampshire
where nearly 32 inches fell throughout
the region officials had warned that the
early storm with winds gusting up to 55
miles an hour would bring sticky snow on
the heels of the past weeks warmer
weather some said that even though they
knew a storm was coming the severity
caught them by surprise so early in the
season and before Halloween seems a
little crazy to have Stoke before
Halloween it's kind of unheard of around
in Maryland you never know you never
know what you gonna get besides the icy
roads turning deadly the howling winds
and heavy wet snow also snapped enormous
trees like twigs and downed power lines
very lucky because I'm alive because if
I was saying the car two more seconds I
will be dead today so thank God for that
New Yorkers have been told to stay off
the roads so that emergency workers can
peer fallen trees and to 10 to power
lines I understand it looks shiny that
sun is shining it looks like it's past
it's not past we have a lot of emergency
crews out a lot of work to do and people
on the roads can sometimes frustrate and
slow the emergency workers who are
trying to get the the lines repair etc
the weather also caused flight
cancellations and delays and train
services were also delayed or suspended
because of downed trees and signal
problems Maine Massachusetts and New
Jersey do not expect electricity
services to be restored for several days
while in Connecticut it could be more
than a week the state has experienced
the largest number of power outages in
its history but not everyone has been
lamenting the early arrival of winter
some ski resorts have started the season
early Julie hide me
Sky News